josh is with us josh is in Colorado
Springs hey Josh how are you I'm doing
all right
for you day better than I deserve what's
up well yesterday literally 24 hours ago
I was called into the office at work we
found out that three of our major
contracts let us go
and so I campaign just let me and 35
other people go oh and at the moment
I've got about $500 I was just starting
on the baby steps after reading the
Total Money Makeover and I'm scared out
of my mind don't know what to do -
Desktop bills coming out the wazoo and
I've got an opportunity where I could
try and get out in over at Wells Fargo
but I don't want to be going in
somewhere where that's against my moral
stand points to be pushing debt on other
people what kind of a position did you
leave I was just
deburring grain I would go through get
all the parts ready to go to customers
so that there weren't any sharp edges
and nobody's gotten themselves on the
parts what were you making about 1125 an
hour and I know that's easy to be fun I
mean I'm I'm a GED kid went into the
army at 17 and was just infantry I don't
have much training outside of that
mm-hmm
so I was using are you single
where to go um I've got my girlfriend at
the moment and I was actually just about
to go out buy a ring and propose how old
are you I'm 25 okay all right well
there's two parts of the equation one
part is the immediate wolf at the door
to have money for food lights water rent
right yes sir now the second part of the
equation is your long term career and if
you don't plan to be somewhere five
years from now and start taking the
steps to be there you're not going to be
there wherever there is
and so you know I think you could
probably be delivering pizzas by
nightfall and be making 1,500 a month if
you do that five or six nights a week
starting now
ready set go on I I've actually got my
girlfriend doing that now is her second
job and unfortunately we only got the
one people and I'm not allowed to try
from working on getting my license died
from a DUI two years ago ooh well that's
out of the question
okay so when were your license supposed
to be back I can get it back at any
point in time I just I've got the sr22
insurance on our vehicle I just have to
get the interlock in and then send the
paperwork to the state and I've got my
license back and then it's just getting
a second vehicle so that I could also do
this delivery driving like so whose car
is this hers or yours this is hers so
you've been Carlos since the DUI yes sir
I've been getting to work she been
riding a bicycle in the running okay all
right ouch
okay um and what do you how much money
do you need to do that's not going to
work um all right that we've got the
sr22 that's $200 a month that we went
through your LP to be able to get that
and the $75 a month would be interlocked
and then it's just waiting three months
for the paperwork to go through with the
state to get my license back yeah and
then you got to get a car and in the
meantime you're trying to buy food and
you need to get some kind of employment
so on exactly I am um okay well I wonder
if the pizza place needs somebody to
cook I mean I don't know I'm I'm just
looking for anything you can do as a
short-term get by a job with its
construction and they come by and pick
you up or snow blowing and they come by
and pick you up and anything you can do
short-term I'm not thinking about doing
this for a career I'm just saying trying
to get a thousand fifteen hundred two
thousand bucks a month coming in there
so you can not only get you a little car
but also get your you know get your
license back those kinds of things and
then
let's start thinking about your
long-term game plan and start taking the
steps to get towards that I'm not a
positive exactly what to tell you in
terms of what kind of a thing to go do
but usually some kind of a self-employed
thing I mean it might be I don't know I
don't know it's some kind of a little
thing you can do for other folks that
that literally they'll come pick you up
to do right now or she can drop you off
to do that gets you started and then
let's get some income coming in and
begin to work back through this mess all
these different things you've got
hurdles you've got a jump you'll get
there but it's going to be a tough year
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish
you